We have seen that several
properties, such as, for
example, linearity of
expectations, are common for
discrete and continuous
random variables.
For this reason, it would be
nice to have a way of talking
about the distribution of all
kinds of random variables
without having to keep making
a distinction between the
different types--
discrete or continuous.
This leads us to describe the
distribution of a random
variable in a new way, in
terms of a so-called
cumulative distribution function
or CDF for short.
A CDF is defined as follows.
The CDF is a function of a
single argument, which we
denote by little
x in this case.
And it gives us the probability
that the random
variable takes a value less
than or equal to this
particular little x.
We will always use uppercase
Fs to indicate CDFs.
And we will always have some
subscripts that indicate which
random variable we're
talking about.
The beauty of the CDF is
that it just involves a
probability--
a concept that is well defined,
no matter what kind
of random variable we're
dealing with.
So in particular, if X is a
continuous random variable,
the probability that X
is less than or equal
to a certain number--
this is just the integral of the
PDF over that range from
minus infinity up
to that number.
As a more concrete example,
let us consider a uniform
random variable that ranges
between a and b, and let us
just try to plot the
corresponding CDF.
The CDF is a function
of little x.
And the form that it takes
depends on what kind of x
we're talking about.
If little x falls somewhere here
to the left of a, and we
ask for the probability that
our random variable takes
values in this interval, then
this probability will be 0
because all of the probability
of this uniform is
between a and b.
Therefore, the CDF is going to
be 0 for values of x less than
or equal to a.
How about the case where
x lies somewhere
between a and b?
In that case, the probability
that our random variable falls
to the left of here--
this is whatever mass there is
under the PDF when we consider
the integral up to this
particular point.
So we're looking at the area
under the PDF up to this
particular point x.
This area is of the form the
base of the rectangle, which
is x minus a, times the height
of the rectangle, which is 1
over b minus a.
This is a linear function in x
that takes the value of 0 when
x is equal to a, grows linearly,
and when x reaches a
value of b, it becomes
equal to 1.
How about the case where x
lies to the right of b?
We're talking about the
probability that our random
variable takes values less
than or equal to this
particular x.
But this includes the
entire probability
mass of this uniform.
We have unit mass on this
particular interval, so the
probability of falling to the
left of here is equal to 1.
And this is the shape of the CDF
for the case of a uniform
random variable.
It starts at 0, eventually it
rises, and eventually it
reaches a value of 1
and stays constant.
Coming back to the general case,
CDFs are very useful,
because once we know the CDF of
a random variable, we have
enough information to calculate
anything we might
want to calculate.
For example, consider the
following calculation.
Let us look at the range of
numbers from minus infinity to
3 and then up to 4.
If we want to calculate the
probability that X is less
than or equal to 4, we can
break it down as the
probability that X is less
than or equal to 3--
this is one term--
plus the probability that X
falls between 3 and 4, which
would be this event here.
So this equality is true because
of the additivity
property of probabilities.
This event is broken down into
two possible events.
Either x is less than or equal
to 3 or x is bigger than 3 but
less than or equal to 4.
But now we recognize that if we
know the CDF of the random
variable, then we know
this quantity.
We also know this quantity,
and this allows us to
calculate this quantity.
So we can calculate the
probability of a
more general interval.
So in general, the CDF contains
all available
probabilistic information
about a random variable.
It is just a different way of
describing the probability
distribution.
From the CDF, we can recover
any quantity we
might wish to know.
And for continuous random
variables, the CDF actually
has enough information for us to
be able to recover the PDF.
How can we do that?
Let's look at this relation
here, and let's take
derivatives of both sides.
On the left, we obtain the
derivative of the CDF.
And let's evaluate it at
a particular point x.
What do we get on the right?
By basic calculus results, the
derivative of an integral,
with respect to the upper limit
of the integration, is
just the integrand itself.
So it is the density itself.
So this is a very useful
formula, which tells us that
once we have the CDF, we
can calculate the PDF.
And conversely, if we have the
PDF, we can find the CDF by
integrating.
Of course, this formula can
only be correct at those
places where the CDF
has a derivative.
For example, at this corner
here, the derivative of the
CDF is not well defined.
We would get a different value
if we differentiate from the
left, a different value when
we differentiate from the
right, so we cannot apply
this formula.
But at those places where the
CDF is differentiable, at
those places we can find
the corresponding
value of the PDF.
For instance, in this diagram,
at this point the CDF is
differentiable.
The derivative is equal to the
slope, which is this quantity.
And this quantity happens to
be exactly the same as the
value of the PDF.
So indeed, here, we see that the
PDF can be found by taking
the derivative of the CDF.
Now, as we discussed earlier,
CDFs are relevant to all types
of random variables.
So in particular, they are
also relevant to discrete
random variables.
For a discrete random variable,
the CDF is, of
course, defined the same way,
except that we calculate this
probability by adding the
probabilities of all possible
values of the random variable
that are less than
[or equal to]
the particular little x that
we're considering.
So we have a summation instead
of an integral.
Let us look at an example.
This is an example of a discrete
random variable
described by a PMF.
And let us try to calculate
the corresponding CDF.
The probability of falling to
the left of this number, for
example, is equal to 0.
And all the way up to 1, there
is 0 probability of getting a
value for the random variable
less than that.
But now, if we let x to be equal
to 1, then we're talking
about the probability that the
random variable takes a value
less than or equal to 1.
And because this includes the
value of 1, this probability
would be equal to 1/4.
This means that once we reach
this point, the value of the
CDF becomes 1/4.
At this point, the
CDF makes a jump.
At 1, the value of the
CDF is equal to 1/4.
Just before 1, the value of
the CDF was equal to 0.
Now what's the probability
of falling to the left
of, let's say, 2?
This probability is again 1/4.
There's no change in the
probability as we keep moving
inside this interval.
So the CDF stays constant, until
at some point we reach
the value of 3.
And at that point, the
probability that the random
variable takes a value less than
or equal to 3 is going to
be the probability of a 3 plus
the probability of a 1 which
becomes 3 over 4.
For any other x in this
interval, the probability that
the random variable takes a
value less than this number
will stay at 1/4 plus 1/2, so
the CDF stays constant.
And at this point, the
probability of being less than
or equal to 4, this probability
becomes 1.
And so the CDF jumps once
more to a value of 1.
Again, at the places where the
CDF makes a jump, which one of
the two is the correct value?
The correct value is this one.
And this is because the CDF is
defined by using a less than
or equal sign in the probability
involved here.
So in the case of discrete
random variables, the CDF
takes the form of a staircase
function.
It starts at 0.
It ends up at 1.
It has a jump at those points
where the PMF assigns a
positive mass.
And the size of the jump
is exactly equal to the
corresponding value
of the PMF.
Similarly, the size of the PMF
here is 1/4, and so the size
of the corresponding jump
at the CDF will
also be equal to 1/4.
CDFs have some general
properties, and we have seen a
hint of those properties in
what we have done so far.
So the CDF is, by definition,
the probability of obtaining a
value less than or equal to
a certain number little x.
It's the probability
of this interval.
If I were to take a larger
interval, and go up to some
larger number y, this
would be the
probability of a bigger interval.
So that probability would
only be bigger.
And this translates into the
fact that the CDF is an
non-decreasing function.
If y is larger than or equal to
x, as in this picture, then
the value of the CDF evaluated
at that point y is going to be
larger than or equal to the
CDF evaluated at that
point little x.
Other properties that the CDF
has is that as x goes to
infinity, we're talking about
the probability essentially of
the entire real line.
And so the CDF will
converge to 1.
On the other hand, if x tends
to minus infinity, so we're
talking about the probability of
an interval to the left of
a point that's all the way out,
further and further out.
That probability has to
diminish, and eventually
converge to 0.
So in general, CDFs
asymptotically start at 0.
They can never go down.
They can only go up.
And in the limit, as x goes to
infinity, the CDF has to
approach 1.
Actually in the examples that we
saw earlier, it reaches the
value of 1 after a certain
finite point.
But in general, for general
random variables, it might
only reach the value
1 asymptotically